as of last week's video we've hit a
milestone we've made it through 10% of
one piece but I'll tell you what it's
been a fun ride having discovered the
origins of the main cast adventures
through Barrett a and Ireland park we
now find our crews sailing away from the
intensely and frankly overwhelmingly
interesting low town with the aim of the
grand line we are finally going there in
this video and I am so damn excited for
it especially after reading the material
for this week's video but I will say
right now drama island was perhaps the
most interesting experience I've had
while reading a manga unlike anything
I've ever reviewed but before that we've
still got a massive journey ahead of us
full of suspense mystery in who knows
what else today I'll be reviewing
chapters 101 to 150 for covering the
reverse Mountain whiskey peak little
garden and drum island arcs so without
further ado I'm totally not Marc and
this is my review first impression and
thoughts on my first taste of the
alabasta saga
[Music]
reverse mountain chapters 101 to 105 in
this short but admittedly charming arc
acting as our first dip into the ground
line and the lore surrounding it Oda
utilizes this also to highlight how
intimidating the grand line can be which
I really liked there are obvious methods
he uses to achieve this like dialogue
and the obvious hearsay within the
litany of villains and characters we've
encountered throughout the story thus
far but in this arc Oda visually
communicates how small and insignificant
the straw hat crew really is compared to
the grand lines monsters and obstacles
both figuratively and quite literally in
these opening chapters to reverse
Mountain this ship Luffy and the crew
are signalling and whether it be on the
snout of a sea monster the opening to a
water passage or a giant whale we are
made to feel extremely small and
vulnerable which we haven't felt
communicated to us yet on this scale
ever in the story and I think it works
exceptionally well to communicate to us
visually how much trouble lies ahead of
us on this journey which is honestly
really exciting and a sort of stuff that
befalls our heroes on this trip is both
interesting and utterly fantastical in
the most wondrous of ways it's explained
to us that the outer perimeter of the
grand line consists of a cam belt that
is full to the brim with sea monsters
thus creating a world where the only
safe means to get into the crime line
and I say safe in inverted commas is
through something called reverse
Mountain within which you have to sail
your ship literally up the river that is
flowing up a mountain and I love this
sort of world building as it employs the
same sort of wonder how a Potter did for
me as a kid it's rooted in the world
adds color and character to the scene
but it isn't too overly silly to make me
step back and say I don't buy it and
once the crew managed to narrowly escape
disaster just entering the grind line
they run into more trouble almost
immediately in the form of an impossibly
large whale that eats the boat and
everyone inside except Luffy who got
launched on top of the wild moments
prior if this is what it's like to just
enter the grand line I can't wait to see
what actually lies ahead for us after
sailing headfirst into the mouth of this
whale the crew eventually meet an old
man living inside who's been assisting
this whale in camming it down with
medicine as it has a desire to
constantly bash his head against the
wall of the red line and it's during
this time Luffy manages to find his way
wael in an attempt to save his friends
only to run into two new characters
going by the code names mr. 9 and Miss
Wednesday who are inside this whale to
kill it and bring it back as meat for
their village through various
shenanigans the two groups eventually
reconnect and together find a way out of
the whale with the help of the doctor
living inside called crocus once this
all happens there's an at first really
compelling and exciting but later a very
tragic story about the present situation
after be following this massive whale
and the life he's had it turns out that
this massive whale's name is called
Laboon and in typical Oda fashion he
can't let me have a cute whale character
to love without him having a tragic
backstory
Otis all like oh you like this whale
well did you know that he's been sad for
the last 50 years and eventually it's
revealed that this whale is proud of a
species that isn't native to this part
of the ocean and came over to this side
when he was a baby he became very close
with a group of pirates and when the day
came for them to leave they promised a
little whale that they would return soon
only to never return now broken
emotionally and later physically from
the despair in his heart the whale has
been torturing himself trying to get
back to his friends essentially having
nothing left to live for and it's
honestly really heartbreaking to watch
but when faced with situations like this
Luffy shows me once again why I love his
character he like most Shonen
protagonists are very emotionally mature
and figures out unconventional ways of
making a situation better his solutions
he challenges the whale to a fight by
attacking stating that they are now
rivals and that he promises to return to
settle the score this lifts the whales
spirits and makes him not feel as
impossibly sad as it did a few chapters
prior it's a really beautiful touch and
I actually really liked this little
gesture the two whalers miss Wednesday
and mr. 9 are forced to beg Lucy's crew
for safe passage back home on the ground
line as their means of navigation has
been lost for without proper navigation
on the ground line you're a goner and
that essentially is the real function
ultimate utility of this arc within the
greater story to explain to us the
readers how navigation works on the
grand line because shakaar it's much
more complicated and dangerous than what
we've been used to so far in this story
no more hopping into a barrel hoping for
the best as you dive headfirst into a
whirlpool on the grand line your regular
compass won't work as
massive amounts of magnetism at play
always couple that with the fact that
currents and tides are unpredictable and
you have yourself a nightmare navigation
situation which sounds bad but is
actually a great band name but there is
a solution to this issue Oda introduces
a new mechanic for navigation in the
wimpy story known as log poses since the
Grand Line is composed of a litany of
small islands these devices then point
towards the closest island in that chain
in a nutshell the pose will point you
all the way to the closest island and
once there you have to wait for the log
post to adjust to the island before you
can move on to the next one in the chain
this is a really clever way for Oda to
force the gang to explore all these
individual islands instead of sailing
towards the ends straightaway while also
providing incentive to adventure around
these islands as they wait for the log
pose to adjust to that island it's a
clever little mechanic that really
serves to push the story into
interesting situations whisky peak
chapter 106 to 114 using their now newly
acquired log pose the straw hat crew
begin making their way to the first
island of the grand line whiskey Peak
mr9 and miss Wednesday Bale almost
immediately once they see the island and
despite inhabitants of that island being
at first extremely friendly serving up
enormous amounts of food and drink to
the straw hat crew whiskey peak later
reveals itself to be a town composed
entirely of criminals who survive by
taking advantage of folks entering the
Grand Line the existence of a town like
this on the Grand Line I really enjoyed
as it makes complete sense and once
again adds another dimension to the
world suggesting that it's had a
successful operation in the past and
like everything else in the world
odors created has been operating with
and without the main cast around
furthering the feeling that this is a
big world that operates when on and off
of screen what's more is that they are
also part of a massive powerful and
mysterious criminal organization known
as the barrel works wherein the main
members refer to themselves by code name
the theme being days of the calendar for
women and numbers for men the lower the
numbers supposedly the more powerful the
agent I'm not sure how the dynamic works
with women though with the head of the
organization being an individual that is
both ruthless and intent on keeping his
identity a secret and we learn all about
this on our first night at whisky peak
because once the straw hat crew fall
asleep the town wakes up and prepares to
apprehend and/or kill Lufia
the gang for the bounty on their heads
which since his defeat of our lung has
been raised to over 30 million berries
and that's when my favorite part of this
arc happens during this sequence on top
of the townspeople he has to contend
with the returning miss Wednesday and
mr. 9 as well as the newly introduced
agents mr. 8 and Miss Monday as I've
said this is when my favorite part of
the arc takes place and it's my favorite
not just because it's cool but because
the actions Oro takes here are once
again informed by character throughout
the show we've seen on a number of
occasions
Zorro sleeping aboard the ship during
what some would describe as inopportune
times for the rest of the shipmates in
this scene and sequence it's revealed
that he does so because he only really
sleeps when he knows he can trust his
surroundings furthermore he refused to
get blackout drunk for this specific
eventualities if I didn't already love
Zoro's character this would be the
moment I'd proposed him and what follows
is an incredibly entertaining struggle
between the forces of the Baroque works
and Zorro okay perhaps struggle is the
wrong word
Zorro dominates every character that
gets in his way with some wonderful
panel work by Oda in the manga this
section really came to life as he dashed
and jumped from rooftops and back alleys
and this could perhaps be my favorite
scene so far with Zorro in the entire
series but unfortunately this arc takes
a bit of a hiss during the next scene
and set of circumstances Luffy's
motivation to try and attack and kill
Zorro made no sense to me here and to be
honest I feel like this might be my
first divisive or really unpopular
opinion in this series so right from the
get-go
let me say I will try to explain my
reasoning for not liking this as best I
can and if you do like it that's totally
cool you are not wrong for doing so so
why did I not really like it well it has
nothing really to do with the visuals
there are some really interesting and
triumphant shots of the characters in
this back and forth and I am more than
interested to see who between the two
would win in a fight but my issues here
however come from what we've learned
about Luffy during the are longer and
this scene directly flies in the face of
all I thought was Luffy's
stablished character Luffy trusts his
crew his friends more than anything or
anyone else
he gave Nami a ridiculous amount of
understanding and leeway and even when
faced with her telling him flat-out to
his face he was still on her side in
addition to that Xaro has not once
betrayed luffy's trust in fact he saved
him on a number of occasions but in this
scene Luffy just straight-up tries to
kill Zorro based exclusively on a brief
interaction he had with a downed
townsperson
this felt much less like typical oda
writing and more like an editor
whispering over his ear saying Zorro and
Luffy are the two most popular
characters you should totally make them
fight but sir that doesn't make sense
Shh needless to say for me it felt
artificial and totally out of character
for Luffy
however thankfully it technically was
inconsequential to the story which from
a fundamentally narrative standpoint
usually is a mark against the fight
itself as everything in the story should
inform the next set of events but seeing
as this was something I thought was
totally ill-fitted in the series I'm
more than happily taken as a brief
unimportant detour in what has been up
until this point a fantastic trip aside
from all of that there's some super
interesting character ideas on display
in the form of yet two more new
introductions that force Luffy and Zorro
to work together miss Valentine a girl
that can change her way to crush her
opponent and mr5 an individual whose
mucus is explosive
both of these fine people have consumed
devil fruit and our officer ranked
individuals from baroque works and
similar to how reversed mountains job
was to communicate to us the basics of
navigation on the grind line as well as
to inform us of the lore within the
world itself so too is whiskey Peaks job
to introduce us to the secret
organization of the Baroque works and in
what began as a routine monkey operation
within the town shortly starts to evolve
the crew in something far far more
involved and dangerous when miss
Wednesday turns out to be an undercover
princess Vivi from the troubled kingdom
of alabasta furthermore mr. ace who
earlier lost to Zorro was also an agent
sent to protect her known as Ygritte
essentially he tells the crew about
baroque works how dangerous they are and
why it's so important for princess Vivi
to return to alabasta right now
and that involving themselves in this
whole undercover operation puts all of
their lives at danger naturally however
the crew agrees and together they vow on
delivering princess Vivi back to her
kingdom
this seems straightforward enough but as
econ leaves in an attempt to create a
distraction allowing the straw hat crew
to escape things become all the more
severe way miss all Sunday the Vice
President and Supreme Commander of the
baroque works makes herself known by
lighting up the sky erase EE grab from
existence
and when Miss all Sunday suddenly
appears on the straw head ship
unannounced is a very palpable new
feeling that descended over me as a
reader
unlike Bucky Krieg or Arlen this woman
doesn't need to shout or curry bravado
over how powerful she really is
she speaks condescendingly while moving
around and takes whatever she wants
without any resistance there's a real
sense of tension as we and the straw hat
crew start to understand the scope of
what they have just agreed to in
transporting princess Vivi back to
alabasta but what makes this encounter
and dialogue exchange all the more
interesting is that miss all Sunday says
that they are heading for little garden
and that there are a number of stops
before alabasta and knowing this she
offers them a long pose that points to
the island of nothing wooden stop before
alabasta which is a strange name for an
island but Luffy I think rightfully
crushes the offered log pose declaring
that she doesn't decide their course but
it makes you wonder was she trying to
sabotage the crew or was she trying to
get them closer to alabasta because it
makes no difference and she might be
entertained by that sighs this mechanic
of log poses an island hopping I really
wasn't sure about when I was first
introduced to it but after experiencing
an abyss it offers a lot in the way of
surprise and adventure due to the nature
of the Grand Line sailing without a log
pose is practically a death sentence
it's a compelling and surprisingly
robust mechanic I have grown to really
appreciate in the story and now with
miss all Sunday leaving them to their
devices we ready ourselves for what
comes next
little garden chapters 115 to 129 off
the set of Arc's little garden is
probably my favorite of them offering up
stunning new designs impossibly detailed
jungle backgrounds some gripping battle
sequences and a phone call conversation
that literally had me at the edge of my
seat
little garden is when things really
start kicking off in the grand lines
narrative and this mysterious scenery
that makes up and composes little garden
is both gorgeous and unnerving the world
building at play here is once again
top-notch shortly after the gang lands
on the island they begin splitting up
for various reasons Vivi heads off with
Luffy to explore Sanji and Zorro
challenged each other to find the
biggest piece two slain leaving Nami a
new stop to take care of the boat page
after page seen
they're seen we are drip fed information
about this place its environment its
native inhabitants and even something
far more massive after learning earlier
in the story how navigation through the
Grand Line works I was scared it would
create excuses for order to deliver
unnecessary chunks of story disconnected
from the greater plot in the hopes of
exploring the scope of the world alone
but thankfully that is most definitely
not the case here as what transpires
while operating in a different new and
exciting area with its own story to tell
is still very much part of the same long
continuous story being told for one
piece and this is achieved solely
through the straw hat crew often times
in episodic self-contained stories the
heroes tend to arrive in a new area on
the most important and exciting day in
that history of that place just out of
sheer coincidence which I really find
contrived and pandering to a certain
extent but because this is treated as
one long continuous story the events
that cause destruction and conflict in
little garden are a direct result of the
main characters and the people chasing
after them being there on that day in
other words Luffy and the crew are the
reason why this story is happening to
this place right now not random
happenstance like other shows tend to
lean on what's more is that as the plot
reveals its hand little garden acts as
the vehicle in introducing us to two
massive Giants who've both been doing
battle for the last century their names
being Dorie no relation to finding Nemo
and froggy both the Giant warriors
who've battled day in and day out all
this time for reasons that have been
totally forgotten with each subsequent
battle resulting in a draw they both
have tremendous amounts of respect for
one another both being great noble
warriors of a land known as L bath and
once o sob learns this about them he
pretty much falls in love with this
philosophy which again is in keeping
with his character however as the
splintered groups of the straw hat crew
befriend each giant new and old enemies
from the criminal organization baroque
works locate the crew and begin
interfering the returning mr. v and miss
Valentine and the newly introduced miss
Golden Week and mr. three who sports the
not so subtle hairstyle depicting his
rank I really like it essentially
they've been sent by their higher-ups to
dispose of Luffy and the others but
while they are there they also want to
claim this still in effect 100 year old
bounty on the heads of the two Giants
needless to say together the forces of
the baroque works massively sabotage the
Giants next battle by tampering with one
of the ale canisters supplied by the
straw hat crew causing a massive
explosion within word of the Giants
mortally wounding them however because
he's a noble warrior that makes no
excuses when the signal comes for him to
battle once again with the other he does
so without hesitation leading to his
combatant take him out for the first
time in a hundred years
and this is when things really start to
go down within this narrative as an
enraged you stop and Luffy who is now
trapped look on in horror before being
attacked by the returning mr. five and
Miss Valentine and to make matters worse
while all that is happening Zorro who
had been hunting for the biggest
creature he could find to beat Sanji in
his little best gets apprehended along
with Nami and Princess Beebe by the
forces of the baroque works trapped
under strange wax structure created by
mr. three who possesses the power of wax
I guess things really aren't looking
good and the set pieces as well as the
fight scenes from this section of the
story are some of my absolute favorite
so far not just from an action
standpoint but also a comedic one Xaro
is ridiculously funny in these scenes
when he's captured this is honestly peak
Zorro comedy as the dire
life-threatening situation combined with
his no-nonsense nonchalant attitude
borne some incredibly funny moments
easily the funniest so far for me dubbed
the candelabra or something to that
effect thinking that Luffy who's up in
the dock monster had taken care of mr.
three traps Zorro Nami and princes Vivi
by their feet in this massive melting
wax structure that slowly is turning the
three into wax statues unable to find a
way out with time running out also
Zarrow elects to assume a fantastically
triumphant pose citing that he would
rather look cool when he dies than to
not I can't deny that logic but before
that with his last minutes of movement
he also elects that the best course of
action is to hack off his legs with his
swords to free himself which borders on
pathological levels of badassery but I
digress
eventually Luffy knew sub shake
themselves off from the prior scuffle
they had an arrival is seen to fight for
their friends but the most impressive
aspect of this story has to be for me
and while this final fight was happening
Sanji hadn't been apprehended yet I was
so sure that he would eventually come
out at the last second to make the save
but he never does instead who's up at
the very end through clever thinking and
a great aim saves the day along with
Luffy I really liked that misdirect for
a few reasons the obvious being the fact
that I was expecting him to be caught
which was a nice misdirect but what
makes it work is that Sanji was the only
one out of them up until this point who
hadn't been yet identified by the beric
works and so it made complete sense that
they wouldn't be looking for him and so
he went on found and in addition to that
the scene he stoled was a pun at the end
of the act is one of the most tense
things I've read one piece so far having
stumbled upon mr. three's base in the
island he intercepts a call from the
main man himself mr. zero he sounds all
kinds of threatening Sanji pretending to
be mr. three confirms that the straw hat
crew has been dealt with and that the
mission is complete however in doing so
Boches the report leading to mr. zero
sanctioning off call the assassination
of mr. three without his knowledge so in
the space of a single chapter Sanji just
bought the team the element of surprise
and averted all attention of the barrack
works to little garden instead I love
this series and to make matters even
better the ones thought to be slain
giant regains consciousness
he was never killed and together the two
giants held the straw hat crew escaped
little gaiden using the log pose
acquired from the barrack works
everything here is connected so
beautifully and it all makes sense which
I adore but what I love most about
little garden and really reversed
mountain and whisky peak as well is that
throughout these storylines we have been
drip fed information we've been
threatened and been made aware of a
spectacularly terrifying entity we've
been warned not to engage with the
tension in a very real way is building
and now it's time for draw Mailand and
before I get into this I want it to be
known that while I don't know what to
expect in this section moving forward I
do know that this particular chapter and
subsequent chapters from this point
onward are considered a big deal which
excites me so without further delay
let's dive right in
why is everybody stopping for this polar
bear sometimes he's mean sometimes he's
nice you never know I get it
he's a bi polar bear draw violent
chapters 132 154 drew island has been
for a long time one of the arcs tons of
you have been telling me to look forward
to and it honestly wasn't at all what I
was expecting but I don't mean that
necessarily in a bad way but beyond
anything else my experience with drum
Island will go down as what I won't soon
forget as it has been one of the most
interesting read throughs I've had with
manga in my entire life from the very
beginning I thoroughly enjoyed the
motivation Luffy and the crew had to
stop the four progression of their
journey and make a detour as Nami
develops a very serious fever this was
enough motivation for me to stop as a
reader as I wasn't sure what was wrong
with her either
so that crease and a media attention and
interest in the story for me once a tram
island I thought the introduction to the
village and country was a good one
learning about their culture
environments wildlife and political
issues once again Oda doesn't
shortchange the world-building as we the
audience are given ample time and space
to explore and learn about this new land
and after learning about the plight of
this land with its deserted King and its
only doctor living atop a massive
mountain by firing away my favorite part
of the story was Luffy and Sanji's
dangerous perilous climb to reach the
doctor with Nami on their backs and I
say favorite not because I don't like
other aspects of this story I do but I
utterly adored this little mini
adventure these two go on as they
attempt to deliver Nami to where she
needs to be all the while avoiding
falling tripping climbing and attacks
from giant rabbit monsters known as
lapid's in addition to that when the
only doctor in the land appears in a
neighboring town indicating to us that
she isn't even in the castle they are
hiking towards it creates a wonderful
sense of tension on top of the already
tense situation created by the two
clamming up there in the first place and
what's funny is I remember sitting down
as I was reading about Luffy and Sanji
riding a tree down an avalanche
surrounded by Giants snowboarding bodies
and thought this wasn't at all what I
was expecting in the best possible of
ways however as things
into more trouble as they often do in
this series the tenacious claim that
Luffy goes on with both Sanjay and Nami
on his back up the mountain unassisted
was by far the most Luffy thing I've
seen and when he arrives on top before
collapsing to the floor I genuinely shed
a tear because he loves his friends that
much that he would kill himself to do
this and despite being on the verge of
collapse hypothermia and exhaustion
Luffy says to the person that finds them
a top of the peak my friends they're my
friends he says this after climbing at
15,000 foot mountain with nothing left
and he would assume in need for help
himself yet he only draws attention to
them it makes me wonder why and how
loyalty has become such a massive deal
for Luffy to an almost absurd degree -
it makes me wonder more about his origin
and what happened to his family in
addition to that this arc had some of
the absolute funniest gags in the series
so far on more than a few occasions I
found myself wheezing with laughter far
more than I even had a little garden
stuff like Zorro starting a fight with
some random solider in the name of
justice but really it's the steel his
warm clothing really got me but the
funniest guy in the entire arc for me
came as princess Vivi in an attempt to
wake up a fading goose up in the snow
slaps the ever-loving daylights out of
his face causing it to swell up a crazy
amount which on its own is funny already
but when Zorro stumbles upon the two he
greets princess baby and stares long and
hard at this swollen face of Aesop's
before recognizing his nose and calling
him by his name I love stuff like that
it's just great character interactions
also worth mentioning the way this arc
ends is both insanely interesting and
raises so many damn questions my head
hurts for gold Rogers name to actually
be Goldie Roger is a friggin awesome
swerve I didn't see coming and makes me
wonder what his connection to monkey dee
Luffy is seen as they seem to be the
only characters with that sort of name
compounding this we are greeted by this
new character called ace that seems to
know Luffy and during some conference
some years ago during Vivi's childhood
flashback we got to see a poster of that
guy from low tide who controlled the
weather this is such a bizarre intro
detailed story and I have no idea what's
to come next in alabaster but I'm really
excited however that isn't all I want to
discuss with regards drum Island as
there are certain aspects I did dislike
in it you see a large part of what makes
shown it as popular as it is is the
empowerment the reader gets to
experience or read about when characters
like Goku Naruto and Luffy restore
balance our justice in the worlds they
operate within also known as beating up
the villains in a lot of ways this
gut-punch Goku eventually gives to
Frieza is cathartic and makes me feel so
damn good
because Frieza is fantastic at being a
villain and this is just one example
there are tons across anime and even one
piece like Ireland don krieg buggy that
even the baroque works i've just been
introduced to heck see luffy deck Arland
that very first plane gave me shivers
but in this act a large portion of the
conflict in tension after Nami recovers
depends on this villain character King
wopo who really for all intents and
purposes is the most overly cartoonish
and least interesting villain I've seen
in one piece so far every scene he's a
this sort of annoyed me and bored me
because of how overly simplistic and how
obvious every decision he made was to
predict unlike Creed he has no once on
like buggy he has no charisma and unlike
our LAN we don't have that strong a
connection to the character he's
threatening just yet in chopper or at
least I didn't yet the only reason I
cared even a little bit about his ending
was entirely down to how much I wanted
chopper to have a happy ending for
himself because I do like the little
guys character and story and while the
ending fight seat had some epic and
totally boss Luffy moments with him
protecting the skull and crossbones on
the tower Apple also might be the
easiest main village fight Luffy has
fought so far in the entire series
but by firing away the single most
interesting thing to ever come out of
this act for me was a scene that caused
me more arguing and confusion than any
other scene I have ever had the pleasure
of reading and that scene was dr. kitty
Luke's flashback sequence showing
Choppers backstory this was a friggin
roller coaster of discovery for me and
I'm not talking about the narrative let
me explain upon reading this sequence in
the manga I really and I mean really
didn't like dr. Harry Luke's character
which is an issue because as it turns
out I am supposed to connect with this
character and think him to be a good
person but I found him to be a veiny AK
for a multitude of reasons and while he
certainly grew and me more as the
flashback continued I never could really
get past that bad taste my mouth when I
saw the character on the page and so
after finishing the arc I explained my
feelings about this story to AJ and in
response he edited out that very
30-minute flashback scene from the drum
Island movie to show me stating that he
thought I got the wrong impression and
so I watched the animated version and
boy is it different in fact it was so
different that I actually ended up
really liking the doctors character in
the movie version and even the anime
version on crunchyroll so much more than
I did in the manga which naturally led
me to bawling my eyes out at little
choppers unfortunate and tragic story
but what was so different about these
versions well quite a lot actually for
instance this is how the movie version
of events plays out it begins as dr.
Hilu Luke's running from the police and
meets dr. kou daija would have the only
other doctors in the place on the bridge
that's how it starts but did you know
that there's a large portion cut from
the original that happens before this
for instance the anime version on
crunchyroll shows a bit more but again I
still sort of liked it in that version
the flashback opens as soldiers
explained to us that by the order of the
king dr. Hedrick is to be captured this
immediately paints him as a sympathetic
character as we all
oh that we hate the king we then cut to
inside a family home where through their
own dialogue they explained the father
desperately needs a doctor but all the
doctors in the area are gone
this creates urgency and paints dr.
Hannah Duke as a courageous character
that is taking his life into his own
hands to protect those around him that's
when dr. healer Duke shows up and tries
to help the family despite being a
terrible doctor against the family's
wishes the mother ends up running to
report him and he makes the dad act like
a frog no big deal and it's sort of
funny he then flees the home not
breaking anything before meeting dr.
Cudahy on the bridge like he does where
the movie version picks up already you
noticed a substantial difference between
the movie and the anime right well
that's nothing compared to my experience
reading the manga bearing in mind that
this was my very first exposure to the
character and scene and I am supposed to
care and like this character for the
flashback to be effective alright here
it is
in the manga the scene opens dogs are
barking with a shadowy figure running
through the snow there's commotion in
the town square apparently here Duke has
burned down at least one home and either
robbed that one or another for money
there is nothing said about the Kings
desire to take doctors or healer Duke
off the streets
it isn't even mentioned that there's a
doctor shortage we then cut to dr. Hilu
Luke who is complaining that he only
managed to steal 50,000 berries and that
they should and I quote quit making such
a massive fuss over a burning house
after this Hilary Duke breaks into a
family home they beg him to leave the
dad even says that he will be getting
treatment by the other doctors here Duke
ignores this request the mother goes to
run for help naturally like any sane
person would do dr. Healy Dukes shoots
the mother with a tranquilizer knocking
her out in front of her small daughter
who is now Paul in crime he perceives to
force this unusual treatment onto the
father only to leave him in what looks
like a seizured state and that's
assuming he isn't already dead
he begins apologizing to the now
traumatized and screaming crying child
as both of her parents are now on the
floor motionless before breaking their
window and running out into the night
where he meets dr. Cudahy on the bridge
and like the rest of them now that is a
substantial difference to the animated
versions and even as the conversation
progresses with dr. CUDA
on the bridge it reveals a horrible
truth about dr. Peter Duke she says
there's nothing worse than an
incompetent physician had you not called
yourself a doctor hundreds of people
wouldn't have suffered from a simple
cold and even the direct translation I
found with the help of friends is worse
both the fan translation and ma
translation and movie translations in
this instance paint him in a much better
light so in the manga the guy is painted
to be a maniac and because Oda wanted me
to sympathize and see him as a good guy
character the entire flashback sequence
was hurt as a result for me thankfully
however because AJ supplied me with a 30
minutes section from the film to watch I
was able to really enjoy both the
character of dr. Healy Duke and
especially chopper who this entire
flashback is for capped off perfectly
with a tragically sweet swerve
incorporating poisonous mushrooms and
the most innocent and tragic of mistakes
by chopper which automatically really
wrapped up and encapsulate the entire
story's message in philosophy with dr.
Hilu whose philosophy still ringing in
the little guy's ear motivating him to
become a doctor that can cure anything
which is an inspiring thought in all I
found this whole experience with gem
Island particularly funny as in the past
I've gone back to watch certain scenes
to see how they play out in the anime
for both my own enjoyment and research
and almost every time I preferred the
experience I had in the manga but this
was one of the only times it was
different and I'm happy I had friends to
point me to spoiler free alternatives
overall I thought the axe this week were
extremely ambitious and I'm glad they
were this was our very first outing into
the Grand Line and with it we've been
exposed to it's crazy navigation
problems its geography through the use
of jungle and winter biomes we've been
introduced to a massive criminal
underworld with its incredibly
intimidating leader we've seen some
fantastic fights learned quite a lot
about how important a character
introduction is in my experiences with
the series and we've also got a new crew
mate in chopper I can't wait to see
what's to come for this ace character
and how luffy knows him but I am
chomping at the bit trying to finish
this script so that I have an excuse to
go and read the alabaster arc that
follows this this is going to be an
incredible adventure and I can't wait to
share it with all of you as always I've
been totally not mark thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you all Nick
[Music]